You would play drinking games too?
We would, not on set, but we
played this brilliant game
called tequila slaps, does
anyone know tequila slaps?
No?
It's just an X-Men thing.
Yeah.
You wanna play?
Yeah, they said you wanted to do something
with me, I don't know
what it is but I'll--
I really wanna play this game.
But I will do it if
you walk me through it.
Okay, so basically two people
stand opposite one another.
One person takes a shot
and before they have time
to swallow it, the other person
slaps them around the face.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
All right.
Did you bring, you brought some?
To call that a game seems--
I know, I don't know.
It's more of a kink than a game.
I don't know how it's a, I
honestly don't how it's a game.
(audience cheering)
And I'll just pour one for myself
'cause I'm getting on a flight
and I'd like to get drunk.
Yeah, just do one for yourself.
And you can have one too.
Oh thank you.
So Andy just gets to have a drink
probably without getting.
That's a big one.
So wait, so okay.
This is the game.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Is it I take this?
I already know who the winner is.
Hold on.
The winner is you because
you get to, should we stand?
Please stand.
Okay.
You're nice and tall, I like that.
Thank you.
Okay.
So you take the shot.
Okay, and how much time do I get?
Just go?
Not much time.
(crowd cheering)
I'm sorry!
(crowd clapping)
Wow!
That was a slap.
That was,
that was a fantastic slap!
(crowd cheering)
That was really hard.
That was--
I'm sorry.
No, that's,
(laughing)
wow!
While she's looking that
way, I'm gonna drink this.
(laughing)
Man, you don't screw around.
I don't screw around.
No, you don't screw around.
No, I once had a purple
hand mark on my face
from playing that game.
And then I came on your show the next day.
Have you hit someone that
hard playing this game before?
Harder.
We go really, really hard with each other.
Now are men slapping you in this game?
Are men slapping you?
Or is it?
I mean, you give them permission, yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's quite a workplace.
(laughing)
But they go gently.
I see.
(crowd clapping)
You gonna drink that whole thing?
I'm waiting 'till the pain goes away.
(laughing)
I'm so sorry.
Don't be sorry, I love that.
That was fantastic, I can
dine out on that for years.
(laughing)
You gotta commit to the bit.
Yeah.
Gotta commit.
The most exciting thing
that's happened to me in a long time.
All right, we have a clip
here from "Dark Phoenix."
I don't even know that
this needs to be set up,
I think government types
have come looking for you
and you're seeking shelter
with some of the other X-Men.
Is that right?
Absolutely.
I did pretty well for a
guy who's been beaten up
and half drunk, let's take a look
at this clip from "Dark Phoenix."
This land was given to
us by the US government.
We have no intention of taking it back.
We're not here for you.
Looking for one of the X-Men, Jean Grey.
Haven't seen her in a long time.
Then you won't mind if
we have a look around.
Do you mind if I came
into your home unannounced and uninvited?
Look,
I know who you are.
I don't wanna fight.
No you don't.
Stop that.
I said stop that right now.
It's not me.
It's me.
Jean.
Jean!
Get down!
(dramatic music)
That is cool.
You did so well!
(crowd cheering)
See, there it was.
You got it.
Hey, "Dark Phoenix" is
in theaters on Friday.
Ladies and gentlemen, it doesn't
get better than this, Sophie Turner!